just grab the ticket it's right there
there's actually a guy puppeting the
robot Oh
oh my goodness this shots incredible we
got to tell people what the heck is
special about this hey what's up welcome
to VFX artist react this is our
emergency green-screen blanket you can
find things like that and more at the
core or digital box store anyways we've
got some great video clips to show you
today to react to awesome classics and
good stuff some stuff that you or these
guys have probably never seen before but
it's mind-blowing pretty cool also hey
Nico isn't today a special day for you
is a special day for me it's my birthday
right into the good stuff here we go I
think this movie gets a bad rap because
of that there's a lot of technical
breakthroughs that came through because
of this movie and then breaking ice
looks really sweet dude this guy is the
best train driver in the world would you
say he's had a lot of training that's
right there grab it just grab it
literally right there and they're not
getting any closer so grab the packet
right there that's somehow we have the
traction to pull the Train out in the
water it's okay it's a cartoon whatever
it's funny you mentioned that it's a
cartoon because at the time they didn't
exactly know how to even classify this
movie Robert Zemeckis did not consider
it to be an animated film because he
directed real actors on a sense yeah
that's what Andy Serkis says too about
his characters but you know what anytime
this motion capture there's a team of
animators they're fixing that mostly I
do not disagree but this is also kind of
like the first time that this was done
for like an entire movie they they film
to pretty much the entirety of this
movie in a 10-foot by 10-foot square
room with a hundred and seventy cameras
pumping out 80 gigabytes of footage per
minute he's way ahead of his time with
this because we're now people are
starting to go towards completely
virtual sets you know the new avatar
movies are kind of feeling this way so
it's also interesting about this movie
is that most of the characters in this
movie were performed by Tom Hanks
they wanted to have the mature
performance of an adult but I made it
weird for like the actual performs cuz
the way a face moves is
on an adult especially Tom Hanks the way
like his forehead wrinkles apparently is
a little different than how kids
foreheads wrinkle they were trying to
make a very stylized movie but at the
same time it's not the same kind of
stylization you get from a Pixar film
like The Incredibles and it kind of lies
in this weird no-man's land
yeah it's like what are we supposed to
make of it the weird stiff facial
animation just feels like somebody was
insisting on making a tech demo in their
movie and it just doesn't feel like the
best option is sometimes the industry
needs tech movies like this to push the
bounds of what we can do ice we're gonna
trouble doing one of those
groundbreaking visual effects movies
from the 90s now this is voted by our
patrons if you want to vote on what we
will react to in the show consider
supporting us on patreon all right let's
do it
twister the tornado movie of the mid-90s
this is like the beginning of those
classic disaster movie tropes looks so
good yeah this is just incredible how
much do you think with simulated vs.
hand animated Ren are you telling me
everything was hand animated oh my god
okay so the only thing that was really
hand animated is the roof of the silo
there as it like falls off kind of
floats towards Cameron and lands right
behind the truck but the thing about the
barn exploding outwards is that that's
all particle based pause read move on
we've got to tell people what the heck
is special about this so these days you
can do physics simulations on computers
we really take it for granted we do
really take it I mean you see it in
video games all the time you have a
stack of cubes they can texture like a
building you can knock it over and
there's your building destruction for
your new Hollywood movie but back then
to do a whole barn game destroyed its
that some really intense physics
simulation and there's a simpler way to
do physics back in the day with particle
systems so particle is just a point in
space so rather than having to deal with
a geometric object you just deal with a
point so when they're destroying the
barn they built the barn out of a bunch
of small 3d models planks panels etc
there are 3,000 pieces in that barn each
3,000 objects just been hand placed by a
modeler at its center has a particle
paired with that object so you're saying
that the particles before the barn is
destroyed are sitting in barn formations
yes they're moving those particles in a
very specific way yes and it pulls that
piece of geometry with it
so I remember seeing this house and
number thinking how did they get a huge
house like that to roll across the
ground and the answer is that the house
isn't real it's a computer-generated
house but it looks so real we know the
guy who worked on this shot his name is
Stu mashed wits he spent six months
working on four shots in this sequence
and it was all hand animated there's
nothing simulated about the shot so
really one day he'd spent like animating
the door falling off its hinges another
day to have some shingles flying off at
the shot right before the truck actually
bites through the house it's 12 frames
and each one of those frames took over
12 hours to render oh my god up to this
point when it comes to visual effects
everything's unlocked off and hammers
have been on tripods in the dekai
directly this was the same guy that
directed speed he's like no I need shaky
cam so the poor poor matchmover is over
at ILM had to sit there and try to match
those camera movements by hand in 3d
shadow shop oh it's like we have
programs that track camera footage these
days to make a 3d camera but back then
you had to do it manually yeah we're so
lucky
so how the heck do they do is trying to
effects so is it like particles is a
little cloud that's flying around just
use trapcode particular
whatsapp Andrew they did not use travel
so first things first you have a thread
so you animate this thread and then
attach that thread is basically a
cylinder or a cone so then they have to
go through and they have to actually
give it this dusty surface one of the
ways they did this basically the same
way your video games render bullet hits
and that is like a sprite based system
you have four hundred five hundred
little points spinning around a central
object basically that being your spline
now if you have a puff just an image of
a puff puff based imagery of a symmetry
you can attach those all over the place
and when you get enough of them till I
kind of fell your shape that's kind of
how you can get your tornado look and
then basically if you're casting light
into your scene and you can have these
sprites these little layers shadow each
other that starts to give you depth as
we need a shading to see volume in our
shots and when all that is stacked on
top of itself it starts to looking
really convincing which is basically the
same method at which we do stuff like
that today in the bus stand dynamics
video when like the robots running off
from the distance instead of doing like
a smoke simulation for it all the dust
being kicked up it's just a puff system
I gave every part of my used to do a job
and it goes through a Chevy tour here's
why this is special they took old
black-and-white World War 1 film footage
and they made it look like modern film
check it out
they just deadly warfare you were facing
the Japanese
Oh
oh my goodness you know what actually is
a pretty incredible stark difference
that's how they're able to actually just
upgrade that and now it's like wow that
wasteland it's like you're there
[Music]
everybody loves the camera bathroom look
at these guys like hamming it up I
noticed how many people had bad teeth
back then yeah that's because really a
parent watching it like this
the other crazy thing is sound if you
hear the people talking you hit the
clothes dressing it's here that the
horses and the Ravens in the background
because back then there's no sound in
the cache it's they've recreated all the
sounds oh my goodness you know it's
really cool
they hired lip readers to go in and read
all the lips of the people no way they
could recreate the audio and the voices
did they hire the bad lip reading guys
cuz that would be amazing
I hate Brenda and a bad guy hit me in
the shin and I peed all on my pants I'll
talk a little about the technology they
use yeah it's pretty crazy to take
something that looks so like raggedy and
torn and noisy and turn that into like
an actual high quality image the company
that actually did most if not all of the
effects for this movie was a company
called stereo D they specialize in
converting 2d films to 3d the reason
there's such a great choice for this is
that in the process bringing something
from 2d to 3d you do a lot of cutting
out of objects in the scene more
rotoscoping than you can possibly
imagine yes and that's how they colorize
this they're going in and they're
cutting out everything in the scene from
a guy's mustache to his face to his hat
to his shirt to his pack to the things
hanging on the back and they have a
palette of colors that they're picking
from and they're recolor izing all these
objects in the scene by hand so you also
notice a little bit of like weird like
motion blur looking stuff and I guess
that's coming from the interpolation
because of the variable framerate that
this was shot in so World War one
they had film cameras but they're all
little hand cranked boxes so literally
you know he's a guy in the middle of
frickin battle in world or woman and
then maybe like Michelle goes out there
by his dad a little bit faster
is that why black and white footage
looks so sped up and layered footage is
meant to be played back at 18 but most
the time it got scanned it got scanned
in at 24 ah but there's shots that are
even like 10 frames per second in this
it was variable it was changed
throughout the course of a shot here
Jackson was saying that to get the
timing right they were just I it up
they'd sit down back let's try playing
it slower a little bit slower a little
bit faster there it is that looks right
oh wow this movie was released in
theaters in 3ds so it's like it's not
just
Old World War 2 footage that's been
colorized it's been colorized and also
made into like this crazy new experience
that you can observe in a movie theater
they shall not grow old I think is a
great example of people using visual
effects to really deliver an emotional
punch so you empathize these people it's
making them characters effectively that
you can imagine yourself being in their
shoes of it is just all-around
fascinating I think it's important for
me we'll also to know history into like
know what has got us where we are and do
not repeat those mistakes in the past
you just got to not kill ferdinand eller
I am actually a big fan of this movie is
that just like a crazy fluid simulation
and animation paid together and actually
is a fluid soon so talk about twister
and trying to simulate things and here's
an example of modern technology is
straight up simulating water instead of
trying to like mimic it I love how they
approached the idea of tars in this
movie which is the robots named
Christopher Nolan was like I want to
make something that is super functional
something that resembles like a tripod
or like a a light stand this robot is
real there's actually a guy puppeting
the robot the way they have the
puppeteer driving those robots is
actually very similar to how they did
c-3po in the Phantom Menace they
basically have a metal pipe connected to
their foot connected to the back of tars
they have their hands on it they're
constantly doing this counterbalance
play right and the thing weighed 200
pounds of G's and there are some shots
where it's not a guy puppeting it it's
actually on a little ATV that's driving
through the water and they paint out the
ATV just leaving just the robot case is
spinning like a gear through the water
and they're getting that as actual
reference which is so important when
doing visual effects it's having
real-life reference when you use
miniatures or heat when you do it for
real you know you get these intricacies
that you only get from reality ok this
shot here full CG in cold water set in
cool Wow unbelievable like that looks so
good that last shot right there when it
runs up you can tell me see how like
they strategize the shot to have the CG
you want in the background and in the
real one in the foreground with the
actor oh yeah good eye yeah motion tends
to be the thing that gives away if
things looking fake motion is also on
things that can really
mask fake things and make them look real
if management is good so in this case if
you're doing physics simulations physics
simulations tend to always look real and
still a little bit of water physics
simulations they're having in the shot
are really selling that is interacting
with reality yeah grounds it in reality
yeah
yes that mother this is the corridor
crew where we got some sick-ass sweaters
look at this
it's dope it's warm as hell and super
high quality throw it in your washing
machine a million times
exactly the same say that about any
other piece of clothing I dare you oh
look at this awesome patterns not only
does it keep them warm in the winter but
also we can track whatever we want onto
it because of our high-tech pattern you
may have seen it in famous movies such
as spider-man what guys here's the real
deal this defensive selling out
incredibly quickly because you have to
order limited quantities we won they did
good close usual that stores where you
want to go to get it spend $75 or more
get free shipping offer your turn city
shop with confidence it's under the road
got doesn't get where this get off your
back and keep it skin wet where belongs
golden digit that story also there's a
link in the description below thank you
so much for watching everyone this was a
really fun episode to do until next time
[Music]
[Applause]
so the big challenge here is how do we
find that authenticity and that voice
here when we ourselves don't have the
same experience as they do all right let
we're taking up we're rolling